BOB, NOT BULLY THEM INTO
SUBMISSION TO SHOW YOUR OWN
POWER, YOUR OWN GRAVITAS.
SPEAKING OF JANUARY 6 THIS
DERRICKS, WE'RE LEARNING
EXCLUSIVELY ABOUT WHAT'S GOING
ON INSIDE THE FBI.
WHISTLE-BLOWERS HAVE FULL
CONGRESSMAN JIM JORDAN THAT THE
AGENCY IS IN FULL-BLOWN
RETALIATION MODE, REFERRING TO
WHAT'S GOING ON AS A PURGE OF
AGENCY EMPLOYEES WHO HOLD
CONSERVATIVE VIEWS.
ONE EMPLOYEE REPORTEDLY HAD A
SECURITY CLEARANCE TAKEN AWAY
AND THEN HE WAS INDEFINITELY
SUSPENDED FROM HIS DUTY AND GOT
HIS PAY TAKEN AWAY FOR
DISAGREEING WITH THE JANUARY 6TH
NARRATIVE.
JIM JORDAN, RANKING MEMBER OF
THE HOUSE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE,
JOINS ME NOW.
CONGRESSMAN, THIS SPECIFIC FBI
EMPLOYER MENTIONED, WHAT CAN YOU
TELL US MORE ABOUT HIM OR HER?
>> DECORATED IRAQI WAR VETERAN
BEING RUN OUT OF THE FBI, HIS
ALLEGIANCE TO THE COUNTRY IS
BEING QUESTIONED BECAUSE HE HAD
THE GALL TO SAY SOMETHING THAT
OFFENDED THE FBI LEADERSHIP
ABOUT THE JANUARY 6TH
INVESTIGATION.
THE OTHER ONE IS ALSO HAVING THE
SAME THING HAPPENED TO THEM
SIMPLY BECAUSE ON AN ANONYMOUS
QUESTIONNAIRE THEY SAID
SOMETHING THAT THE LEADERSHIP
DISAGREED WITH THEM ABOUT
JANUARY 6 BURIED AND I WOULD
POINT OUT, LAURA, THAT WE NOW
HAVE HAD AGENTS COME FORWARD AS
WHISTLE-BLOWERS, TWO ON THE
SCHOOL BOARD'S NARRATIVE, ON THE
SCHOOL BOARD ISSUE, AN END FOUR
REGARDING JANUARY 6TH.
THAT IS A CONCERN TO US BUT WE
HAVE HAD LITERALLY HALF A DOZEN
FBI AGENTS COME TO OUR
COMMITTEE.
>> Laura: IT'S HAPPENING ALL
OVER GOVERNMENT, IS IT NOT, JIM?
IT HAPPENING AT THE FBI, WE KNOW
IT'S HAPPENING IN OUR MILITARY
WITH THE WHOLE STAND DOWN ORDER,
REMEMBER, IN THE SPRING OF 2021
AFTER JANUARY 6TH, SO WE HAVE TO
MAKE SURE THERE ARE NO UNSAVORY
PEOPLE IN OUR MILITARY.
THAT WAS A WARNING SHOT THAT
THEY FIRED ACROSS THE BOW FOR
OUR YOUNG MILITARY MEN AND
WOMEN.
>> EXACTLY, IT'S THE
WEAPONIZATION OF GOVERNMENT
AGAINST HER POLITICAL FOES.
THE LEGACY -- TO GO WITH HER
MONOLOGUE, THE LEGACY WITH --
THE SCHOOL BOARD ISSUE, WRITING
A MEMORANDUM THAT TREATS MOMS
AND DADS AS DOMESTIC TERRORISTS.
THAT'S THE LEGACY THUS FAR IN
HIS TENURE AS ATTORNEY GENERAL,
BUT THIS WEAPONIZATION OF
GOVERNMENT AGAINST HER POLITICAL
FOES IS EXACTLY WHAT'S -- SO
MUCH SO WE HAD A DISINFORMATION
GOVERNANCE BOARD AND BUT FOR
YOUR EFFORTS AND OTHERS POINTING
THIS OUT, THAT STILL MIGHT BE IN
OPERATION.
THAT IS HOW THE LEFT IS
OPERATING -- IN THE CONTEXT HERE
WITH THE FBI, RENUMBER, FEW
YEARS AGO THIS BIDEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP, THE ACTIONS
THEY TOOK AGAINST PARENTS
REGARDING THE SCHOOL BOARD
SITUATION, AND THEN TWO
WHISTLE-BLOWERS LAST MONTH HAD
COME FORWARD WHO ATTENDED THE
JANUARY 6 RALLY ON THEIR OWN
TIME WITH THEIR SPOUSE, DIDN'T
GO IN THE CAPITAL, HAVEN'T BEEN
CHARGED, BUT THEY'VE HAD THEIR
SECURITY CLEARANCE TAKEN FROM
THEM TOO, WHICH IS ALWAYS THE
FIRST STEP IN TERMINATION.
AGAIN, ONE OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WAS ALSO A VETERAN IN OUR
ARMED FORCES.
THIS IS HAPPENING, AND IT IS AS
WRONG AS WRONG CAN BE.
>> Laura: CONGRESSMAN, ON THE
ISSUE OF JANUARY 6, HERE'S THE
CNN REPORTER RYAN NOBLES, WITH I
THOUGHT WHAT WAS A STUNNING
EMISSION, WATCH.
>> IS LARGELY GOING TO BE A
CONTROLLED MESSAGE, EVEN THOUGH
THERE ARE REPUBLICANS ON THE
PANEL.
THESE REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS
ARE WORKING IN UNISON.
THAT MEANS THAT'S GOING TO BE NO
OPPOSITION VOICES DURING THESE
HEARINGS.
>> Laura: THAT IS LAUGH OUT
LOUD HILARIOUS, JIM.
THIS IS THEATER, AND THEY ARE
UPSET THAT WE ARE NOT RUNNING IT
LIVE ON FOX?
IF THERE IS THEATER, IF THEIR
PRODUCTION, THEIR PROPS, THEIR
WARDROBES, THEIR MAKEUP,
WHATEVER THE HELL THEY'RE DOING.
IT'S ALL ON THEM, THAT'S WHAT
THEY WANTED.
>> AND THEY'VE USED TAXPAYER
MONEY TO HIRE THE FORMER
PRESIDENT OF "ABC NEWS" TO
CHOREOGRAPH THE DOCUMENT OR THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO PRESENT ON
THURSDAY NIGHT AND OVER THE
COMING WEEKS.
SO YEAH, THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT IT
IS, CHOREOGRAPH, BROUGHT TO YOU
BY THE TAXPAYER -- THE TAXPAYER
EXPENSE.
IT
>> Laura: TO WE KNOW HOW MUCH
IT'S COSTING, BY THE WAY?
MOTHERS WHO CAN'T FIND BABY
FORMULA.
WE HAVE PEOPLE STRUGGLING TO PUT
FUEL IN THEIR GAS TANKS.
HOW MUCH IS THIS COSTING?
THIS LITTLE SHOW?
>> I DON'T KNOW, BUT I DO KNOW
YOU'RE RIGHT, THERE WILL BE NO
COST -- IS THE ONLY COMMITTEE
HEARING I'VE EVER SEEN IN
CONGRESS WHERE THERE WAS NOT AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CROSS-EXAMINE
WITNESSES BECAUSE THERE IS NO OR
REPUBLICAN AND ON THAT COMMITTEE
WHO WILL DO IT, SO THIS IS WORSE
THAN WHAT ADAM SCHIFF DID IN THE
BUNKER IN THE BASEMENT WITH
IMPEACHMENT BACK IN 2019, AT
LEAST I GOT TO BE IN THAT ROOM
AND DEPOSE WITNESSES AND THEN
WHEN THEY HAVE A HEARINGS, WE
GOT TO CROSS-EXAMINE WITNESSES.
BUT IN THIS SITUATION COME UP
THAT'S NOT EVEN HAPPENING, SO
THIS IS COMPLETELY CHOREOGRAPHED
PRESENTATION, COMPLETELY
PARTISAN, THE GOOD NEW